tell them about the idea i had for it
for us
would you got an idea no i don't know
i'm not entertaining this hey i don't
want i love you i love you i'm good all
right i'm going to pitch you the idea
[ __ ] it all right late on me brandon
don't be shitty i remember two weeks ago
it was brandon toads
hundreds of thousands of dollars we
actually made some money on it yeah we
actually made money all right
okay so so ready so
um so
travis scott hella concert in the
fortnite space uh-huh how come
how come we don't own the first meta
comedy club
where you can [ __ ] digital comedy club
yeah where you go you can sign up
anywhere in the world you're in hold on
hey do you mind
we have our own comedy club you
virtually can attend
anyone we can do a we could do a [ __ ]
comedy night and anywhere you are in the
world you pay five bucks to to be
in our comedy club our medic comedy club
what
why
you're welcome guys that was already
happening during the pandu because yeah
[Applause]
no i'm thinking about this so if we had
like a green screen so you have a green
screen you'd get up and you do your
stand-up you could actually have a live
show but it's a green screen i'm about
to show you guys a picture i watched
like i know we've done it he doesn't
know so now you you did instead of zoom
you you actually you you virtually enter
the room you can virtually get your room
but still you're not in person and
you're in a con you're you're there and
you're actually you can see people next
to you
and now you're actually watching
comments it's a zoom but you know is
that the future though i don't think so
live comments yeah i guarantee if you
ask any of those kids that attended that
fortnight concert would you rather be in
person yeah or have the headset
no doubt
isn't that something they would do
without being see that's totally
different that's not what i'm talking
about no brian also that only worked
because it was the pandemic
he wouldn't have done that if it wasn't
no but
because i remember exactly where i was
when i first heard about the first one
but wait if you can't go to a concert
right say you're in i don't know your
[ __ ] wherever it is yeah and you
have your virtual goggles and you're
sitting down in a theater in a digital
theater like go to have you seen mark
zuckerberg's [ __ ] metaverse
go go show that for a second watch this
so now you're so now you're actually in
a theater watching comedy next to people
but you're not though you're right
but it's better than
something i i just so we look like
characters yeah yes like you have you
seen what they're able to do now watch
this metaverse [ __ ] you wanna watch the
trailer of it or yeah watch it it's
[ __ ] it's it's that [ __ ] looks
[ __ ] stupid yeah but it's it's crazy
watch how people are going to be taking
meetings now
it's it's nuts it's nuts see i'm not
talking about digital comedy i'm talking
about
like literally that's digital so what we
have so so this is all fake behind
company brand to encompass everything
that we do gotta get a weird [ __ ]
reflection why because he looks like a
robot we hope to build how many bodies
our company is now
meta now you're in here
you're you're this is this is you can
create any room you want imagine
you put on your glasses or headset and
you're instantly in your home space you
can choose whatever you want to do no
whatever you want hey
hey look i'm telling you right now look
at me yeah i know it's the future yeah
we get it
listen look at me
now give me let me let me let me pitch
you now now do you have the funding to
build an entire meta universe
it's so easy so wait people would think
that they're in the theater watching us
is what you're saying dude
i [ __ ] what instead why don't you
just go to those markets we're gonna do
it live bro but are there we want to
reach the world
five bucks
you come into the [ __ ] i don't know
what we call it
we have our meta theater the meta club
dude the meta club listen yeah because
martin luther is not
copyrighting
it's the first [ __ ] comedy club that
we we create our own first comedy club
you can put on your glasses you get in
the cup you take your seat and you watch
us get up on stage and do stand up i'm
just telling you that is going to happen
so we're only performing for them
there's no one there's no idea it's pay
to be in the [ __ ] audience you have
to pay you have to pay five dollars to
put your [ __ ] glasses on and wherever
you are in the world you can come and
watch us do our special but hey dude
hold on no come on
nope somebody no
yes
dude you admit what's wrong with his eye
i know he's an average what's on you
what's all over your arms i had those
burned off that's
more burned off well i told you he's
gonna do more no that was the same day
and and that was the same day jack oh
and she went oh she went let me do the
whole she goes let me see and of course
all right so she's just throws them off
yep but it's all going away yeah it's
just scabs yeah yeah it's gonna be
nothing to get more done no i won't gent
it no i won't i don't have stuff done
yeah you do excuse me imagine if i had
like botox in my face that's only a
matter of time dad no i'm not getting
botox uh
no i'm sure people are going to be doing
it but isn't this weird how everything
behind them is fake not at all
i mean
that's what we're going to be doing dude
you're going to be in the theater hey
we're going to be doing it
oh
you're going to be good
my time this is like this is one year
away
get the work done now 15 years it's
going to be it's going to be long i'll
tell you what how about this how about
this ready seven how about this yeah i
built i'm gonna have it built okay i'm
gonna have it built yeah and we're gonna
be the first comics the three of us
to do a show someone's gonna do it
no they're not you should save this up
here dude
yeah no it's great hey i said it first
it's not original yeah you said it first
so you know it is original i'm an
original thinker see now you're you're
kind of coming over to my
we'll have a crowd you can have a crowd
as well how are we going to have a crowd
just like just like get like seats and
stuff like that i've done that but i was
like
why not where are you at this weekend
i'm glad you asked off the hook comedy
club there you go
and i linked you up with my boy yes so
you're naples why not just broadcast it
on youtube yeah you're on stage
because you're not in the theater so so
with with this with youtube you're
watching it on your screen if you have
your glasses with metaverse you're
actually in this yeah it's a fake but
it's a fake but you feel like you're in
there like people like dude
i'm just telling you as this technology
oh no that's gonna be the future for
sure yeah but i think it's it i think
what happens is you will be able to
reach everyone you want and so if
somebody can't afford how do you do a
tour huh you don't you can't tour that
you wouldn't be able to tour of course
you can tour you can also tour i'm just
saying you could hold these these sort
of like
shows if you wanted for the world so
anybody anywhere who's a fan of yours
but why wouldn't you just go over there
in person like yeah like africa
you can also do that but i mean think
about the difference if you if you
wanted to reach a bunch of people say
it's a half hour instead of doing a
special
you can just say this this special is
now you can come to my special you can
watch it in the better verse yeah in in
my metaphor burn the material yeah
and i don't know if you have to burn the
material because what happens is you can
only see it if you paid that five
dollars so one of them and then it goes
away yeah one of the cool things you
can't screen grab it you can't record it
the thing about the metaverse is you
have to pay to be in it so now you're
you're doing literally a show for only
people who are willing to attend
i i think you have the goggles yeah it's
so crazy man i miss the way it's going i
guess
i don't like that you're i know you're
trying to do this you're so all about it
dude i'm a futurist